alors patrick c'est le dialoguiste qui
sort ça va être ta fête et nous faire la
fête ce soir encore dans touche pas au
poste alors 4x venait avec côté de moi
on va chanter la fiesta ensemble j'ai vu
que vous avez vous avez pas balancer ça
ils peuvent faire entrer ce qu'ils
veulent tous jouer en lever la baisse
les chroniqueurs
je vous rappelle tout ce qu'on va se
retrouver ce soir dans touche pas à mes
jeux télé avec toute l'équipe du raca il
y aura vers 3h utilisateurs ceylan
patrick enlever le bouchon prenait le
micro pour les microbes à patrick lui
prenait le micro ma patrie allez-y
et attention c'est parti on va chanter
la fiesta
camille est en toi y'a pas de problème
attention c'est parti vous fait rentrer
ce que vous allez c'est parti
musique onema
ma belle j'ai moi c'est toute la cèze
alors fait délaisser sa faveur
ce soir je rêvais
mr a créé jours
m
pinault
babel
c'est le
la fsa
la star
c'est ça
autre atout de ce soir
truc
mais patricia tous
vous